[Music]
you
[Music]
a trachea esophageal fistula is a birth
defect in which the esophagus has an
abnormal connection to the trachea
the esophagus is the tube that food
passes through from the mouth to the
stomach and the trachea is the windpipe
that air passes through from the mouth
and nose to the lungs
the trachea forms during the sixth week
of pregnancy
here you can see the tube that will
eventually form all the organs of the
digestive system
the trachea and lungs grow from the part
of the digestive tube that will
eventually become the esophagus
for unknown reasons the esophagus and
trachea may grow and separate abnormally
during this time the esophagus may end
in a blind pouch with missing gaps and
be abnormally narrow this absence or
narrowing of a natural body passageway
is called atresia the esophagus and
trachea may also have an abnormal
connection called a trachea esophageal
fistula
here we see the most common type of
trachea esophageal fistula in a newborn
infant the upper esophagus ends in a
blind pouch and the lower esophagus
connects to the trachea
this is a serious problem because
stomach contents can travel up the
esophagus and pass through the fistula
into the trachea and lungs
and also cause difficulty breathing for
the newborn since air can now bypass the
lungs and enter the stomach
before a trachea esophageal fistula
repair procedure an intravenous line
will be started the baby may be given
antibiotics through the IV to decrease
the chance of infection the baby will be
given general anesthesia which will put
the baby to sleep for the entire
operation a breathing tube will be
inserted through the mouth and down the
throat to help the baby breathe during
the operation
the surgeon will make an incision in the
baby's chest usually on the right side
through the incision the surgeon will
gently move the lungs aside to view the
trachea and esophagus
after identifying the trachea esophageal
fistula the surging will slowly close
the fistulas connection to the trachea
with sutures then cut the connection
away from the trachea the fistulas
connection to the esophagus will also be
cut and the fistula will be removed
next the surgeon will make an incision
at the end of the upper esophagus to
open it
then the upper and lower esophagus will
be connected with sutures
finally the surgeon will insert a
surgical drain in the chest and close
the incision with sutures
after the procedure the baby will
continue to use the breathing tube until
they've healed enough to breathe on
their own
the baby will be taken to the neonatal
intensive care unit for monitoring pain
medication will be given
the baby may continue to receive
antibiotics through the IV babies are
released from the hospital when they're
able to eat enough to maintain their
weight which may be after two weeks or
longer